la revue de presse de dominique souchier
dominique bon bonjour
et bien voilà c'est fait mon cher
philippe on parle déjà de nous dans les
journaux ce n'est pas encore tout à fait
la gloire mais enfin presque car avant
même que nous ayons dit le moindre mot
il ya déjà des réactions
le figaro par exemple met en garde ce
matin ses lecteurs sous le titre suivant
la radio des copains ce n'est pas très
gentil la radio des copains mais ce qui
l'est un peu moins ce sont les
commentaires car le figaro affirme dans
un article non signé que sous couvert
d'adopter un ton moins agressif nous
nous apprêtons riom en fait à nous
livrer un endoctrinement en règle adouci
précise tout de même que journal adoucie
par quelques pages musique le quotidien
de paris lui est plus neutre il constate
simplement que france inter part ce
matin d'un nouveau pied et publie une
longue interview de jean noël jeanneney
à la fp qui est publié aussi par de très
nombreux journaux de province et dans
laquelle le patron de radio france nous
fixent eux tout simplement comme
objectif de reconquérir la génération de
1968 celle des 30-45 ans ce qui ajoute
t-il comme si cela ne suffisait pas ne
veut pas dire que france inter perd face
et autres auditeurs
quant au journal libération il apparaît
lui très vivement intéressé puisqu'il
est écrit votre modestie dut-elle en
souffrir que tout le monde devrait
gagner à l'arrivée de philippe caloni
sur france inter simplement regrette ce
journal c'est pas très malin de la part
de philippe caloni d'avoir fait pleurer
les auditeurs de france musique vendredi
matin lorsqu'il a fait ses adieux
voilà c'est signé jsb et ça se trouve en
page 39
ah oui il faudra encore attendre
quelques temps avant de faire la une et
cela d'autant plus qu'un journal fait
aujourd'hui l'événement le matin est son
influence du film qui a été diffusé hier
soir sur tf1 les hommes du président
y aurait-il aujourd'hui un mini effet
watergate en tout cas vous verrez en
regardant la une de ce journal qu'il n'y
a pas que la presse américaine
la presse française aussi fait parfois
des révélations le matin publie en effet
à partir d'aujourd'hui une série de
rapports confidentiels défense et qui
sont signés des chefs d'états majors des
trois armées terre air mer et dans ces
différents rapports ces militaires
s'inquiètent de la volonté apparente du
ministre de la défense de ne pas
augmenter dans les années qui viennent
la part du budget de la défense
si cela devait être explique ainsi le
général de le nez ce serait très grave
car cela aboutirait non seulement à
réduire l'armée de terre de 30000 hommes
dans les années 80 4 88 mais aussi à une
armée de terre a faibli dans ces
structures vieilli dans ses équipements
a peintes dans son moral tout cela je le
répète figurant en toutes lettres dans
un rapport confidentiel défense adressé
le 9 octobre dernier par le général de
l'onu et chef d'état-major de l'armée de
terre à son supérieur hiérarchique le
général lacaze chef d'état major des
armées
sachez enfin que les hebdomadaires le
point le nouvel observateur vous propose
cette semaine une cure de jouvence
le premier le point en publiant une
longue enquête sur les jeux vidéos qui
font cette année fureur il est vrai avec
quelques bonnes années de retard sur les
américains puisque la balle
électroniques représentent déjà 50% du
marché du jouet quant au nouvel
observateur il vous apprend cette
semaine à part les jeunes ou si vous
préférez verlan ou argot tendre et comme
je suis sûr que vous êtes déjà branché
gens viendraient tout de suite à la
troisième leçon
troisième leçon donc raul et jenny
partent en soirée oui j'ai dit en soirée
car voilà belle lurette que les jeunes
ne vont plus en boum la boum aujourd'hui
c'est le nom qu'on donne aux goûters
d'anniversaire dring dring donc c'est
jenny est lente ou se dit raul
elle aimait table cette poule je lui
mettrais bien une brioche au chaud
soupire jean il aimait tab ce mec
qu'elle screens
c'est dommage qu'il ait quelques cracks
hausse sur la gueule whitera pause ça
veut dire bouton raul de nouveau j'ai un
plan colossaux on va chez max génie le
méchant plan max c'est génial et
incidents fin de la troisième leçon
raul et jenny quitte la casbah de
comprenait un coq et 5 pièces
prendront-ils la mob la meule la bresle
la bécane la caisse ou la poubelle
à vous de choisir car comme cela se
produit souvent dans l'est le centre au
cab eu l'air nous avons l'embarras